les maladies cognitives touche plus d'un
demi million de personnes au canada la
plus connue alzheimer une maladie
irréversible qui détruit les cellules du
cerveau et causent des troubles de la
pensée de la mémoire mais il est
probable qu'un patient diagnostiqué
alzheimer n'est finalement pas cette
maladie mais un autre type de démence
c'est ce que détaille cette étude parue
dans la revue brain l'auteur principal
c'est le docteur nelson joint au
kentucky
on pensait que c'était alzheimer en fait
un tiers des cas étudiés avaient sept
autres maladies late qui veut dire tard
car elle touche surtout les patients de
plus de 85 ans la majorité des gens
entre 65 et 85 ans une combinaison de
deux protéines déjà connu amélioré d'
état mais l'article en question
mentionne la possibilité d'une troisième
protéines ou maladie commence ici pour
cet autre spécialiste de la maladie
d'alzheimer
cela pourrait expliquer pourquoi les
essais pour un traitement échoue
jusqu'ici la réponse allait médicament
expérimental différends entre les
différents types
on parlait justement la semaine dernière
d'un patient traité pour alzheimer
précoce mais il est mort et on s'est
rendu compte qu'il n'avait pas alzheimer
il avait l'oeil il y a à montréal la
plus vaste banque de cerveaux du pays et
ils seront auscultés avec un regard neuf
la nouveauté ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
une troisième priorité n'a cherché on
espère du vivant de la personne met
évidemment en vo réexamine itno cerveau
à la banque
ici aux deux pour voir si cette protéine
est effectivement aussi présente que
décrit dans l'article
avec l'espoir que dans un futur proche
on parle enfin d'un succès dans le
traitement de la démence
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal